Oregon Senator Jeff Merkley is making
his second trip to the border demanding
answers about the zero tolerance policy
two weeks ago he was blocked from
touring a children's immigration
facility near the Mexican border but
yesterday the senator and other
Democrats visited that children's
facility and other Border Patrol centers
senator mark lee joins us now senator
it's very good to see well it's good to
be with you I think it's taken a minute
but I do think finally this this
conversation is front and center you
came two weeks ago why well I came
because I had heard these stories of
children beaten ripped out of their
parents arms and I thought that can't be
right that can't be true here in America
that families are waiting asylum fleeing
persecution abroad are then being
persecuted here in the US so I came down
to find out and what did you find out
yeah I found out was it's true that
right here in this facility across the
street children are being separated from
their parents they're being shipped off
to detention centers like the one in
Brownsville where where I thought two
weeks ago the rumor was a thousand
children are being held
turns out it's almost 1500 kids are
behind those doors
see Padilla was here earlier and he said
you know but many times you have gang
members you have criminals that are
using children as pawns to get inside
the borders here what do you say to that
well I visited ten mothers yesterday
evening who'd been separated from their
children and all kinds of different
conditions I don't think any of them
were gang members they were absolutely
frantic about what's occurred to their
kids and what will occur to them this
has become seemingly such a political
partisan issue the president trumpet
said the demmer he's blaming the
democrats for this
there have been no Republican senators
here do you wish that some of your
Republican colleagues had come and is
this a problem that the Democrats are
causing yes I absolutely wish my
Republican colleagues would come down I
did hear over the weekend the Susan
Collins and Jeff Flake were speaking up
about this policy we're here in the end
evangelical leaders starting to speak up
we're here in the Southern Baptists
starting to speak up and so I hope that
we'll get more space for my Republicans
to feel like they too can champion the
fact that here in America we don't treat
people in this fashion as they're
awaiting an asylum hearing but or your
Republican colleagues reaching out to
you well the ones I've talked to have
said Oh Jeff we completely agree with
you this is terrible policy and we're
going to call up and whisper to the
administration but they won't say it
publicly why do I don't think they'll
say something publicly I think they feel
that there is their their basis is
watching news media if that is so far to
the right they're describing this as the
choice between open open borders versus
afflicting families and that's not the
choice at all we've had programs case
management programs work very carefully
to keep families together
awaiting asylum if they're going to be
minted for asylum we don't want to
mistreat them if they're going to be
miss deported we don't want to mistreat
them I mean these that you mentioned
Lady Liberty and indeed Lady Liberty has
said give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
and now she's saying if you're fleeing
affliction abroad and wash up on our
shores
we will handcuff you we will throw you
in prison and we will rip away your
children do you worry that the world is
certainly watching this story do you
worry that there are perception in the
world will and will do you worry that
people will be negatively influenced
about their opinions about us watching
what they see
oh absolutely for so long we have been
champions with human rights around the
world we have talked to other dictators
who are engaged in ethnic cleansing who
are engaged in afflicting minorities and
said stop that's not the way you treat
people and it's not the way you treat
refugees coming to your borders there's
a whole international protocol of
respect and dignity for Refugees getting
a fair hearing and yet here we are
violating it and the president keeps
saying it's a law and he's blaming the
Democrats what is your message well my
message is this is completely an
administrative decision they announced
it may 7th they implemented it in April
as you mentioned in the first six weeks
2,000 children were separated not
because of the law yeah but because of a
trump decision and now that can be
changed it can be changed in a moment in
a moment Father's Day so we hope you
have a change it on Father's Day all
right senator Merkley that did not
happen we thank you for standing here
with the bugs flying around you can't
see but the bugs are tearing him up
thank you very much really appreciate so
much it's not comfortable here let's
send it back to Nora in New York you
know Gail it's so interesting to hear
some of your reporting as you've been
talking to the families and also to dr.
Colleen Kraft who talks about the effect
that this will have on children who've
been separated
they're from their from their parents it
really is heartbreaking and you know
Nora when I was in the facility what you
see is that these are parents who care
about their kids there's a father whose
little boy is laying in his lap he's
rubbing his head there's another father
somebody's hot riding there's a father
who's stroking his daughter's hair
there's a mother another mother who's
just rubbing her daughter's back these
are all people that just say we just
want a better life and they are willing
to risk their own lives to be here so
imagine you get here and you think
finally I made it and then you're
separated from your children and you
have no idea where they're going or when
you'll see them again
that's what's so frightening you don't
know where they're going and you don't
know when you're going to see them again
I know Chief Padilla said they're given
a list and told exactly where their kids
are going to be that was not what I saw
yesterday and that's not what I heard
yesterday either
all right Gayle thank you